the public facing three fundamental
truths of
Scientology maybe correct me if I'm
wrong a man is an immortal spiritual
being like with said with Satan's his
experience extends well beyond a single
lifetime so infinite memory backwards
his capabilities are unlimited even if
not presently realized
the capabilities are unlimited yeah so
that when I say Godlike I really just
mean you know Thanos like Unlimited
scientologists don't believe in a God so
when I say God like I just mean the most
powerful entity the Creator the the
prime mover unmoved except we are all
that you know a thing in definition in
Scientology a thing has no position in
space or time methane does not actually
exist in the physical Universe it might
choose to locate itself in the physical
Universe right and then forget that it
made that decision and then sort of get
caught and trapped in the physical
universe but that once the thing is uh
restored to its native powers
um everything you see here in the
physical universe is just a thing
playing a game
like letter we are in a simulation right
now of some fateen so like physics
doesn't have to make sense when we're
talking about it this way like
technically urethane i'metha and we're
here but because this could also all
just be another thing's game so Satan's
all the way down yeah it's just Dayton's
everywhere things it all comes down to
the thing is there an idea of a God
because I read there's a kind of there
is a sense of a Supreme Being because
that basically the thetan that's at the
core at the bottom of it all yes not not
defined undefined correct Scientology
has this concept of the dynamic
accelerate Hubbard breaks life into
eight different Dynamics and the a
dynamic meaning a Thrust towards
survival so he would say you know first
Dynamic is you yourself second Dynamic
is your family third Dynamic is any
other group that you're a part of other
than your family fourth Dynamic is all
humankind uh the fifth Dynamic is plant
and animal life all non-human life uh
sixth Dynamic is the physical world
seventh Dynamic is sort of like
spirituality collectively
and the eighth Dynamic L Ron Hubbard
says Scientology doesn't deal with the
eighth Dynamic but we recognize that
people have this idea of a Supreme Being
and so Scientology says you can call the
eighth Dynamic the Supreme Being Dynamic
but we call it Infinity just the allness
of everything without having to Define
it and then they sort of do a little
dance and they're like Scientology the
purpose of Scientology is to get you to
the point where you have your own
understandings or realizations about the
nature of the eighth Dynamic we don't
tell you what you have to believe about
that and technically speaking that is
true technically speaking that is true
there's no point in Scientology where
they sit you down and say you're now
required to revoke your belief in a
Supreme Being it's just that everything
in Scientology is is inconsistent with a
belief in the Supreme Being
you can still find scientologists who
through cognitive dissonance will tell
you they believe in a supreme being
mostly they're lying to you how's this
inconsistent with the Supreme Being
because like Satan's because Satan's
have created everything not God
okay so things creative they they're
also creative for us they're not just
the force that runs everything right but
can't those be just the fingertips of a
god sure the only way you could
reconcile a Supreme Being
is if you say a single Supreme Being
created
all Theta
yeah like the spiritual Big Bang yep but
that's not what most people think when
they say when they talk about God
they're talking about a creator of the
physical Universe yes so there's no
Theta right
I mean even as I've described
Scientology so far none of what I've
said is something I even subject to
riddle cool this is pretty Common Sense
stuff actually I mean if you believe in
spirituality or Spirits at all there's
nothing I've described so far that's
crazy yeah you know believing in past
lives isn't particularly unique or
special right
um the fact that Scientology does this
little dance of pretending to believe in
a God I mean it's even like a PR line
Scientology Representatives will tell
you you can be a Christian and be a
Scientologist well let me tell you what
Christians don't believe in past lives
and lives on other galaxies and planets
and universes they but and Scientology
knows that Scientology knows you can't
be a Christian and be a Scientologist
but they will say that it's just an
example of sort of the fundamental baked
in dishonesty because it's so important
to Scientology on the organizational
level to have text exempt status
I wonder how do you do you know the
process of what it takes to prove that
some an organization is a religion while
going through that process with the IRS
for the second time by the way
Scientology actually had tax exemption
in the early days and the IRS pulled it
and then they got it back in 1993. while
going through that process again the IRS
actually took issue with the fact that
Scientology was claiming you could be a
Scientologist and a member of another
religion the IRS actually said
pump the brakes there yeah if you're
going to say that
we're going to say you're not a religion
yeah and they actually in put in writing
to the IRS no no no no that's not what
we meant that's not what we meant
we meant in the beginning you can be
both but eventually you just have to be
a Scientologist